Nói ra, kém cũng mọng đằng sau phùa của nóng được năng thần.
Còn gất thiết, nèm thị cú cố gắng đi nào, nghĩa là thống phân nỏa, không chắc đi mười.
Nếu như một tiêu của kém, kết tại nó được em là tầm sau bạch.
Có ăn gì đăng gái hai cô đau.
Đúng sai kém của bỏ kỳ đây, cái bất cả người quán khó.
Nếu nó được mình chưa tới thì mình cứ nào như đây cũng,
phọt ngại như thế để, mình nghĩa sản quán,
bột con như bà đà một tiêu chiến người thì cái bạch nó thì tập trung của bạn nào.
Cái cú cố gắng, cái cú cố gắng, bấm dựa để mừng xin xem nào.
Qua tình đây, cái cạnh trị tây đó, có bội tối,
kèm biệt mùa đe, kèm tạm tạm tạm, tạm nó nó được, kèm biệt thì mình đi nữa.
Nhiệm đi được, nó nó được, biệt thì mình đi nữa.
Trong rất là thêm mình, phy hoa bó.